married you are who's the lucky lady I
know you what do you mean I'm gonna
arranged marriage what assisted marriage
that's what we're calling these days
What About Love
like really modern and real I could
relate to her it's like very
unjudgmental she's dating around she's
sleeping around she's figuring out what
she wants and I think that's um really
cool to show in a movie like this you
know she's not a saint
what you still can't say it
oh that's good exactly what I just said
especially was so sort of
scattered and scatty and mad and a bit
tackless and I think there's an awful
lot of people like that they don't mean
to be rude they're not meaning to be
racist or something just say saying
things that they haven't quite thought
I'm very lucky to have them as neighbors
actually they've become like family to
me since your father left for that
teenage she's 35 exactly I've been
growing up watching rom-coms loving them
my favorite kind of movie so it would be
me in the world if this could have
latched on to that Zeitgeist or that
moment so I hope people go and watch it
we love making it and this is special
this is different exploring something
more you know exploring this like
different look at different cultures and
the East and the west and their ways of
falling in love so that's unique I used
to think that I was scared of being with
the wrong person but now I realize that
I'm scared of being with the right
person